sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
zuseherinnen und zuseher herzlich
willkommen am institut für
friedenssicherung und konfliktmanagement
an der landesverteidigungsakademie in
wien ich bin generalmajor johann frank
leiter dieses institutes und darf sie
durch die heutige veranstaltung führen
hier am fk beschäftigen wir uns mit
allen fragen die die sicherheit
österreichs bewegen wir analysieren die
konflikte von westafrika über den
mittleren osten den west balkan bis nach
osteuropa und russland
wir analysieren fragen der europäischen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik und
bereiten diese ergebnisse für lehre
öffentlichkeitsarbeit und politik bereit
beratung auf
unserem bildungsauftrag folgend arbeiten
wir aber nicht hinter verschlossenen
türen daher haben wir uns auch
entschieden die heutige veranstaltung
filmisch zu präsentieren und somit einem
breiteren publikum zugänglich zu machen
das thema der heutigen veranstaltung
lautet modelle für ein europa der
zukunft in gegenwehr in der
gegenwärtigen geostrategischen und geo
kulturellen lage sie werden sich
vielleicht fragen warum dieses thema für
die landesverteidigung für das
österreichische bundesheer relevant ist
meine antwort darauf ist einfach es gibt
keine österreichische sicherheit ohne
europäische sicherheit das ausmaß der
handlungsfähigkeit der europäischen
union in sicherheits- und
verteidigungsfragen bestimmt ganz
maßgeblich auch die sicherheit
österreichs
daher ist eine realistische einschätzung
der grenzen und möglichkeiten
europäischer sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische zusammenarbeit
von äußerster bedeutung für unsere
sicherheits politischen und
strategischen planungen
für dieses thema konnten wir kaum einen
geeigneteren
gastreferenten finden als professor
herfried münkler professor münkler ist
emeritierter professor für
politikwissenschaft an der humboldt
universität in berlin
er ist autor zahlreicher
standardwerk zur politischen
ideengeschichte und zur kriegs theorie
und träger mehrerer wissenschaftspreise
zuletzt hat er mit max wagner und
nietzsche eine welt im umbruch ein neues
werk das sich auch mit den geo
kulturellen grundlagen europas
auseinandersetzt veröffentlicht
herr professor vereint in seiner person
den anspruch in unseres instituts
nämlich profunde wissenschaftliche
analyse mit politik orientierter
praxisorientierter politikberatung zu
verbinden lieber herr professor müller
herzlich willkommen in wien
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
heutige veranstaltung wird in zwei
teilen organisiert wir beginnen im
ersten teil mit dem gastreferat und
lagen anschließend werden wir die eine
oder andere facette aus dass aus diesem
referat gemeinsam in einer
podiumsdiskussion
vertiefen
abschließend möchte ich möchte ich eine
kurze thematisch inhaltliche überleitung
durchführen und zitiere dabei den ersten
satz der ersten europäischen
sicherheitsstrategie aus dem jahr 2003
dieser satz lautete noch nie in seiner
geschichte war europa so frei so
wohlhabend und so sicher
20 knapp 20 jahre später finden erneut
strategische grundsatzdebatten in der
europäischen union statt es wird an
einem neuen strategischen grundlagen
dokument gearbeitet den sogenannten
strategischen kompass und in diesem
dokument finden sich aussagen wie europa
ist in gefahr
europa droht an den rand der weltpolitik
gedrängt zu werden und europa muss
lernen die sprache der macht zu sprechen
um in einer zunehmend konfrontativen
geopolitischen gesamtlage
sich seine eigenen interessen das
europäische lebens und
gesellschaftsmodell behaupten zu können
sehr geehrter herr professor münkler die
welt ist offensichtlich wieder einmal im
umbruch
was ist in diesen knapp 20 jahren also
einer historisch gesehen sehr kurzen
zeitspanne geschehen was ist geschehen
in europa was ist geschehen um europa
und was geschieht mit europa diese und
viele anderen fragen wird uns nun herr
professor müller in seinem gastreferat
ausführen und wir freuen uns schon sehr
auf seine ausführungen und die
anschließende diskussion sehr geehrter
herr professor ich darf sie um ihre
worte bieten
ja vielen dank für die einladung nach
wien der ich gerne gefolgt bin um ein
paar überlegungen zu dem vom general
frank gerade umrissenen problemen
horizont vorzutragen
man hat europa in der vergangenheit also
konkret natürlich die europäische union
mit einem fahrrad verglichen das immer
in bewegung sein müsse um nicht
umzufallen nicht so bald es steht vieles
um
das waren wir natürlich
keine besonders befriedigende
beschreibung europas und deswegen ist
dieses fahrrad bild relativ bald mit dem
begriff der finalisierung der eu
überzogen worden das bezog sich darauf
wie viel mitglieder wird sie in einem
endzustand haben und wie wird dieser
endzustand
aussehen
das sollte gewissermaßen ein ankommen
ein verein stellen des fahrrads in den
fahrradständer
darstellen aber man hat sich
in den letzten 20 30 jahren eigentlich
nie über diesen endzustand verständigen
können
der titel meines vortrages heißt modelle
für europa dann ist die panther die ich
im weiteren entwickeln möchte eigentlich
die dass die zeit der beliebigen modelle
die man sich so ausdenken kann vorbei
ist und dass wir als europäer inzwischen
unter einen handlungsdruck geraten sind
der ein modell letzten endes uns zwingt
zu favorisieren
denn das ist die erste these europa die
europäische union ist von außen unter
handlungsdruck geraten und zwar so sehr
dass sich brüssel ich das mal als kürzel
für die eu im nachfolgenden verwenden
darf nicht mehr darauf beschränken kann
nur regel politik zu machen oder
wesentlich regel politik zu machen
sondern sie gezwungen ist handlungsmacht
zu entwickeln
sie sehen vielleicht ich mir da zwei
begriffe die der
rückfahrt mittel aufgebracht hat in dem
buch das europäischen pandämonium auf es
spricht allerdings von regel politik und
ereignis politik ereignis politik ist
ein begriff mit dem ich nicht sehr viel
anfangen kann deswegen ersetze ich ihnen
durch handlungsmacht
handlungsmacht ist etwas was
gewissermaßen sich nicht auf die ihn
inneren rechtszustand der eu bezieht
sondern in hohem maße nach außen
gerichtet ist
der zwang die
europäische union aus einem mehr oder
weniger dichten dass wir bislang immer
die diskussion und auch der gegenstand
der kontroverse wie dicht soll er sein
der regelungs raum in einen politisch
nach außen handlungsfähigen akteur zu
verwandeln also gewissermaßen eine
operation durchzuführen
am
zuckenden objekt
hat vielerlei gründe
der erste grund ist die diversion
politik russland
also man kann das auch als eine politik
des spiegels
bezeichnen
die russen
konzentrieren sich in hohem maße darauf
schwächen der europäischen union zu
identifizieren ihren weiteren sinn
moralischen überlegenheitsanspruch zu
konterkarieren und auf diese weise
spaltung jeden innerhalb der eu auf zu
tun oder zumindest die zentrifugalen
kräfte zu intensivieren zweitens die
einflussnahme chinas im rahmen der 17
plus 117 +1 formats also den gesprächen
in china wesentlich mit den
osteuropäischen da war 16 plus
griechenland jetzt 17 staaten führt
gleichzeitig mit der finanzierung
bestimmter projekte bei denen es im
ergebnis zur folge hat dass
entscheidungen der europäer die china
negativ betreffen in der regel von dem
17 die medina besonderer weise sprechen
dann blockiert werden
und drittens die erosion dessen was man
den westen genannt hat und teilweise
auch immer noch nennt
aber
den gibt es ja in dieser form die er in
der zeit der ost-west-konfrontation
bestanden hat nicht mehr
eine zweite these ist also das alles ist
die folge eines scheiterns das nach 1989
bis 91 oder 89 91 verfolgten weltordnung
projekts
eine vorstellung wie die welt nach dem
ende der bipolarität aussehen könnte das
wesentlich auf regeln aufwerten und
aufnahmen begründet sein sollte
dieses projekt ist
denke ich
gescheitert
also und zu sagen wir sind heraus aus
einer situation in der wir uns im fälle
der wünschbar keiten bewegt haben und
hineingeworfen in eine situation die
sehr viel stärker
durch reaktion auf äußere
herausforderungen gekennzeichnet ist
wie sehr dieses weltordnung projekt nach
89 91 gescheitert ist kann man daran
sehen dass einer der zuletzt
aufgekommenen leitbegriffe
schutzverantwortung nicht wisst
possibility to protect der als
völkerrechtliche grundlage humanitärer
interventionen
und begrenzung
das leid begriffs der alten weltordnung
nämlich souveränität gedacht worden ist
aus unserer
gesprächskultur völlig verschwunden ist
das war sozusagen
ein kurz aufleuchten das licht und das
ist weg
man kann auch sagen
die vorstellung dass internationale
gerichtshof der strafgerichtshof an die
stelle des austragung von konflikten mit
waffengewalt treten sollen auch diese
vorstellung ist
zusagen aus der politischen agenda
wieder in den allgemeinen im weiteren
sinne politik theoretischen
philosophischen reflexionen raum
zurückgetreten die idee dieser welt
ordnung war machtfragen in rechtsfragen
zu verwandeln
davon müssen wir uns verabschieden
russland und china haben von anfang an
auf ihre souveränität bestanden und
eingriffe in ihre souveränität
immer wieder zurückgewiesen in der regel
und der verweis darauf dass er eine
einmischung in ihre inneren an
gelegenheit nicht so dass große teile
eigentlich der welt sich gar nicht
diesem projekt gefügt haben und konnte
man sagen okay so eine weltordnung ist
aber ein work in progress und das kann
nicht von einem tag auf den anderen
verwirklicht werden haben aber es kommt
noch dazu dass die islamische welt zu
einem raum geworden es in dem der westen
insbesondere die usa von afghanistan bis
zum irak von libyen bis syrien
gescheitert sind mit der implementierung
der werte und regeln
es waren vor allen dingen die usa die
sich unter kramp krachend und unter
beiden jetzt mit dem rückzug aus
afghanistan
vorsichtiger aber in der nacht
bemerkungen dazu dann doch auch sehr
deutlich von dieser weltordnung
verabschiedet haben wenn beiden erklärt
die zeit des humanitären
interventionismus sei vorbei
das heißt aber nicht dass
an die stelle einer weltordnung die
einen hüther hat ein hüter derweil die
vereinten nationen unter dem strich zu
schwach sind letzten endes von den usa
übernommen worden ist dass diese hüte
abgelöst wird durch einen anderen etwa
china china betreibt keine politik des
globalen hüters und deswegen wird auch
nicht auf ein amerikanisches zeitalter
oder einer pax americana ein
chinesisches zeitalter oder einen packs
sinica folgen sondern wir werden es mit
einem anderen modell von weltordnung zu
tun haben dass gekennzeichnet ist durch
die einflusszonen der großen mächte also
gewissermaßen rückkehr zu einer alten
weltordnung
weltordnung durchaus in
anführungsstrichen wenn man sie eher
beobachten kann in der europäischen
geschichte
innerhalb dieser einflusszonen werden
dann die jeweiligen akteure ihre eigenen
werte geltend machen
aber sie werden sie allenfalls als
universelle werte behaupten aber
sie werden und sie werden nicht mehr
darauf setzen diese
im globalen maßstab umzusetzen
wenn das so richtig ist können wir sagen
die europäische union war eingestellt
eigentlich ein bestandteil einer solchen
regel orientierten werte von wirten norm
getriebenen weltordnung zu sein und hat
und der maßgabe dessen dass diese
ordnung sich durchsetzt auch darauf
verzichtet verzichten können geglaubt
sich das leisten zu können
eine handlungsmacht nach außen zu
entwickeln denn man wollte ja
gewissermaßen bestandteil einer
rechtskultur und
einer wenn man so will werte politischen
aufsicht
sein
diese zeit ist vorbei wer das nicht
akzeptiert denke ich wird diskussionen
führen die vielleicht akademisch
interessant sind aber politisch
folgenlos bleiben
das also ist die dritte sie ist europa
hat eigentlich gar keine freie
modellwahl mehr sondern es geht nur noch
um die frage ob
sie in der im entstehen befindenden
weltordnung der großen mächte
objekt oder subjekt sein will
das ist meine dritte die ist es gibt für
die europäer wenn sie zukünftig
überhaupt eine rolle spielen wollen
einen zwang zur umstellung von innerer
regel dichte auf äußere handlungsmacht
man die nicht hat spielen dann auch die
regeln im inneren und die eigenen rolle
und die eigenen werte keine rolle mehr
sondern sie haben eine allenfalls
rhetorische relevanz als eine form von
ach wie gut dass wir mal darüber geredet
haben
das bittere es das gilt dann auch für
die politik in sachen weltklima
also wer diesen fragen eine große
bedeutung zumessen muss bereit sein dazu
beizutragen europa zu einem relevanten
akteure zu machen
und dabei hilft auch nicht weiter zu
sagen europa muss ein vorbild sein ich
möchte es mal zuspitzen wer auf die
vorbild these sich einlässt gesteht
damit
unbemerkt aber andere dann schon merken
seine handlung schwäche ein
ich will dass kurz an zwei beispielen
erläutern am umgang mit belarus oder
locker schenker
man hat vor einiger zeit also man die
europäer in reaktion auf dessen umgang
mit der demokratiebewegung sanktionen
verhängt die einerseits den universellen
anspruch der eigenen werte und normen
unterstreichen und andererseits belarus
zum einlenken bzw zur politischen
zurückhaltung
bewegen sollten
gewissermaßen im gestus
bezug auf das projekt der entstehenden
weltordnung der regel werte und normen
orientierung belarus auf den rechten weg
zurückzubringen mit einem mittel der
sehr begrenzten sanktionen man hat
offenbar nicht damit gerechnet
dass man gegen maßnahmen ausgesetzt ist
nicht das in minsk oder in moskau oder
wo auch immer analysiert wird nun ist
denn eigentlich die zentrale
vulnerabilität verwundbarkeit dessen der
hier sanktionen über uns verhängt und
meine
eigentlich hätte jeder meiner studenten
einem strategie seminar mann gewesen ist
relativ schnell herausfinden können dass
die zentrale verwundbarkeit der europäer
sagen sie haben es ja auch öffentlich
immer wieder sichtbar gemacht in der
migrationsfrage und vor allem in der
verteilung von migranten besteht so dass
gewissermaßen das der ansatzpunkt war
manche auszuprobieren wie nehmen es denn
die europäer mit ihren eigenen werten
wenn sie plötzlich mit herausforderungen
konfrontiert sind
mit diesem gegen handeln der russischen
bilder russischen seite sind wir zurzeit
konfrontiert und was wir sehen ist
gewissermaßen ein dementi in polen der
eigenen werte vom push bergs
über die art der verteidigung eine
außengrenze
jenseits dessen was man an werten und
normen
kommuniziert hat und möglicherweise dann
auch eine hebung von leuten die nach
polen reingekommen sind und dann nach
deutschland weiterkommen seitens der
deutschen seite wir beobachten also
einen strategisch hoffnungslos
überforderten akteur der in diese
situation geraten ist weil er sich auf
regeln verlassen hat und die geltung
dieser regeln werte und normen und nicht
mit einem strategischen gegen handeln
anderen seite gerechnet hatte und kann
es daran sehen dass man keinen plan b
hatte und auch nicht in der lage es im
augenblick die ihren daran zu hindern
ihre flugzeuge an weißrussland zu lesen
um aus dem irak oder wo auch immer her
menschen dorthin zu schaffen
ein anderes beispiel wenn das ebenfalls
in diese richtung
verwaist ist die bereitstellung von
impfstoffen zur vip 19 für das was man
früher mal die dritte welt genannt hat
china russland und auch die usa haben
überschaubare impfstofflieferungen
analog zu militärhilfe gleichsam
inszeniert um verbindlichkeiten und
verpflichtungen bei den auf diese weise
belieferten zu generieren
die eu dagegen die unterm strich am
meisten geliefert hat hat ihre hilfe
weitgehend über die unesco abgewickelt
so dass sie gar nicht als
eine hilfe und eine leistung der
europäer der eu sichtbar gemacht worden
ist
das heißt die europäischen lieferungen
haben keine geopolitischen effekte
erzielt
man könnte auch sagen es hat den letzten
zweieinhalb jahren eine geopolitische
veränderungen zum nachteil europas
stattgefunden die kommission hat in den
kategorien der alten weltordnung also
der weltordnung die nie wirklich
entstanden ist vorstellungen von
89 bis vor kurzem gedacht
und ihre hilfe als eine hilfe letzten
endes der vereinten nationen
inszeniert und ich die folgenreichen
veränderungen der weltordnung im
hinblick auf die bildung von
einflusszonen sich eine sich vorgenommen
wenn man das allerdings realisiert dass
wir es mit einflusszonen zu tun haben
dann muss man auch bereit sein zu sagen
es ist eine spezifische europäische
european
und nicht von irgendjemanden und einer
allgemeinen weltordnung ich komme damit
zum schluss
fünf schlussfolgerungen die daraus
resultierende jetzt nicht unter dem
gesichtspunkt der politischen
machbarkeit oder der wahrscheinlichkeit
sondern sozusagen als eine imperative
die aus dem resultiert was ich
vorgetragen habe und letzten endes daran
auch hängt das gebe ich gerne zu dass
man die voraussetzungen nicht formuliert
habe oder die lageanalyse zuteilt
erstens
nicht die regel dichte im innern sondern
die handlungsmacht nach außen wird über
die zukunft der europäischen union
entscheiden
in sachen selbst behauptungen wie in
fragen der ökonomischen prosperität bei
der beschaffung von verbündeten
nur zu sagen in der zweiten welt die
also der welt derer die nicht zu den
großen akteuren gehören wir schaffen von
verbündeten und unterstützern und
im hinblick auf die glaubwürdigkeit der
für den eigenen einflussbereich geltend
gemachten werte und normen aber nur für
diesen bereich zweiter
anstelle der bisher im zentrum stehenden
harmonisierung der wirtschafts und
sozialpolitik wird es zukünftig
um die herstellung einer gemeinsamen
außen und sicherheitspolitik gehen
diese veränderung wird zugleich ein
hebel zur veränderung der gesamten
europäischen union sein denn in dem
augenblick
verändern sich die einfluss verhältnisse
und auch die relevanz der akteure man
kann sich das vielleicht zu vorstellen
dass die europäische union die ihr ein
raum ausräumen ist nicht nur der raum
der mitgliedschaft sondern schengen-raum
euroraum und so weiter es sollen einen
weiteren raum gibt nämlich den raum
derer die sich an einer aktiven außen
und sicherheitspolitik beteiligen und
die
meine analyse stimmt dann die rhythmik
des europäischen geschehens vorgeben
zurzeit haben wir es mit einer dominanz
der zentrifugalen kräfte in der
europäischen union zu tun da ist nicht
nur die trennlinie noch zeit die vor
allen dingen fiskalpolitisch aber
wirtschaftspolitische fragen betrifft
seien auch die trennlinie west ost in
der es um verfassungs und
rechtspolitische fragen geht
die sind erkennbar im vorgegebenen
rahmen der verträge nicht lösbar aber
sie werden wenn sie nicht gelöst werden
zu einer agonie der eu führen
entweder in der form dass
die nettozahler staaten zu einem
rückzug aus dem was man mal investment
in kamen kurz also der finanzierung von
gemeinschaftsaufgaben
sich entschließen oder aber wenn sie das
nicht tun und da sind sie sozusagen
zwischen skylla und charybdis mit einem
wachstum von populistischen parteien im
innern rechnen müssen was ihre
handlungsfähigkeit dann in deutlich
einschränkt
also
der von mir
beschriebene aufbau einer sicherheits
und außenpolitischen handlungsmacht ist
zugleich die voraussetzung für eine
veränderung der eu im innern mit dem
ziel eine
auflösung der zurzeit
eingetretenen
dominierenden zentrifugiert herzustellen
viertens
eine zurechnung zu den gestaltenden
akteuren der geopolitischen und
geopolitischen ordnungen wird von zwei
fähigkeiten abhängen nämlich dem aufbau
und geltend machen eines eigenen willens
gegenüber
anderen seite mal den anderen vier
wänden in dieser ordnung 5 eine rolle
spielen als da wären die usa und china
der ersten reihe
russland die europäer wenn sie zusammen
bleiben und diese handlungsmacht
aufbauen und als fünfter vermutlich
hähnchen
also die fähigkeit eines europäischen
willens gegenüber den vier anderen
erstens und zweitens die fähigkeit zur
pazifik ihr und stabilisierung der
jeweiligen peripherie denn jeder dieser
fünf großen wird eine peripherie am bein
haben im falle europas sind dass vor
allen dingen die gegenüberliegende
mittelmeer küste
mit der sahel-zone dahinter
teile des nahen ostens und das system zu
sagen für österreicher natürlich mit
besonderer weise relevant
dieses raums der vom balkan über die
schwarzmeerregion mit der ukraine im
norden und der türkei im süden bis in
den kaukasus hineinreicht
die fähigkeit zur partie führung dieser
räume
geld polizei mit versprechen politischer
art gegebenenfalls auch mit
militärischen mitteln ist sozusagen ein
lackmustest ob man zur lesung fünf
akteure und gehört oder nicht das heißt
die europäer müssen zwei fähigkeiten
entwickeln nämlich erstens sich zu
behaupten in den pufferzonen
an denen die großen einfluss in denen
die einflüsse der großen akteure
aneinanderstoßen das ist aktuell belarus
und ukraine
gleich auch moldawien ein anderes
in verbindung mit dem aufbau so etwas
wie digitaler abwehrfähigkeit und
zweitens sie müssen in der lage sein
diese räume der unordnung der anime
einigermaßen zu organisieren
ein fünftes und letztes
ein
europa wie ich es geschrieben habe ist
das gegenmodell zu einer eu die
weiterhin an ihren inneren ihrer inneren
regel struktur arbeitet und sich nur auf
die konzentriert
nicht beachtet dass der ausbau der regel
struktur tatsächlich die zentrifugalen
kräfte gestärkt haben und
die gleichzeitig nicht in der lage ist
diese regel struktur denke an ungarn und
polen
im innern auch zur geltung zu bringen
wo der die jedenfalls in einem
intensiven disput über die bedeutung der
regel sich befindet
ein solches europa ist geopolitisch
nicht relevantes bild keine rolle
und es wird deswegen auch mit der zeit
erodieren und sich auflösen
das heißt die zeit des pokals der
modelle ist dass es die hauptthese
dessen was ich vorgetragen habe vorbei
es gibt eigentlich nur noch ein modell
das aus der
äußeren imperative und der inneren
deposit der eu resultiert und das heißt
umstellung von regel politik auf
handlungsmacht vielen dank
ja lieber prof
dank für diese exzellenten und präzisen
auf den punkt gebrachten aussagen die
wir jetzt sind weiterer folge in dieser
diskussionsrunde etwas vertiefen dürfen
dazu darf ich unsere beiden diskutanten
kurz vorstellen wir gehen auf der
rechten seite professor max gottschlich
vom institut für praktische philosophie
der universität linz herzlich willkommen
und zu meiner linken seite dr johannes
bergdolt bei uns am institut zur
zuständig für grundlagenforschung sehr
beschäftigt sich mit den grundbegriffen
zu sicherheit souveränität freiheit und
zeichnet auch federführend
verantwortlich für die heutige
veranstaltung mit ich mich hier auch
schon herzlich bedanken möchte ja sehr
geehrter herr professor ich habe
aus ihren ausführungen für mich
mitgenommen europa steht vor einer
doppelten strategischen herausforderung
wir haben eine gleichzeitigkeit von
äußeren herausforderungen von massiven
veränderungen in der internationalen
strategischen lage und diese treffen auf
eine eu die mit sich beschäftigt ist die
vielfach vielfache interne krise die sie
angesprochen haben von der migrations
krise über die finanzkrise bis zur
erfindung der pandemie krise zu
bewältigen hat und die zeit der
intellektuellen
spielereien wenn man so etwas plastik
formulieren möchte wie sich europa in
zukunft entwickeln möchte in welche
richtung man den tieren möchte ist
vorbei es gibt klare strategische
notwendigkeiten für ein europa der
zukunft das viel stärker auf die
entwicklung äußerer internationaler
handlungsmacht setzt
soweit diese these ich glaube auch aus
unseren analysen können wir das auch
jedenfalls unterstreichen wir sehen das
auch sehr ähnlich für mich stellen sich
hier zwei fragen einerseits aus dem
militärischen bereich kommend
ist natürlich verteidigung ein kern
merkmal von staatlicher souveränität
und man könnte jetzt aus analytischer
sicht feststellen die die meisten
vielleicht sogar alle eu staaten haben
ihre verteidigungspolitische ihre
militärische souveränität bereits längst
verloren und können sie nur auf
gemeinsamer europäischer ebene in form
einer gemeinsamen einer kollektiven
souveränitäts ausübung wieder gewinnen
um angesichts der großen nacht
potenziale der anderen vier globalen
akteure bestehen zu können aus politik
wissenschaftlicher sicht kann es so
etwas geben wie eine gemeinsame
kollektive souveränitäts ausübung
es kommt drauf an ob man es probiert
nicht natürlich ist es schwierig und wir
sehen das ja im augenblick an den
an dem verhalten polenz dass in der
frage seiner außengrenze nicht mal
frontex ran lassen will sondern sagt das
ist unsere eigene geschichte dass es ein
unterschiedliches souveränitäts
verständnis innerhalb der 27
eu-mitglieder gibt nicht also sozusagen
die
im rahmen der osterweiterung der eu
hinzu gekommenen akteure haben natürlich
nachdem sie sowohl eine gewissermaßen
die gefolgsleute
moskaus gewesen sind
fast antiquiertes souveränitäts
verständnis
dass auch mehr in bekundungen besteht
als den tatsächlichen fähigkeiten aber
sagen sie bestehen darauf die
bundesrepublik deutschland und ich würde
auch mal sagen wenn mancher hinsicht
österreich haben eine
der historischen erfahrung und auch eine
realistische analyse ihrer fähigkeiten
er sehr modifiziertes souveränitäts
verhältnis deutschland kann man sagen
haben sie ja ist eigentlich
bekommen wieder souveränität jedenfalls
im weiteren umfeld aber es ist das eine
und zusagen im völkerrechtlichen sinne
über souveränität zu sprechen und das
andere im tatsächlichen sinn nicht
angesprochen digitale souveränität
gegenüber den usa dass man nicht
angewiesen ist darauf die geheimsten
geheimnisse europäischer geheimdienste
in den clouds amerikanischer
privatunternehmen abzulegen und
andererseits digitale abwehrfähigkeit
gegenüber des informationskampagnen oder
auch angriffen auf die steuerungssysteme
der europäischen mitgliedsstaaten
seitens russland oder von mir auch als
russischer hacker oder was auch immer ja
und das ist aber völlig klar da haben
wir einen rückstand auf andere
den können wir eigentlich als europäer
nur gemeinsam aufholen und dann muss man
das glaube ich so machen wie das mal bei
dem airbus projekt war als man auch
festgestellt hat beim bau von zivilen
flugzeugen
sind wir hoffnungslos zurück und wenn es
dann geschafft hat tatsächlich
aufzuholen nicht und das ist vielleicht
so etwas wie ein hoffnungszeichen dass
man sie in diesem falle auch könnte aber
man hat nicht mehr viel zeit darüber
herum zu spekulieren ob man sollte
sondern man muss es man muss wirklich
damit jetzt energisch anfangen und
vielleicht die
pause die man hat durch den die wahl des
us-präsidenten beiden
schnell und zügig nutzen bei
möglicherweise schon bald das window of
opportunity wieder zu ist
wenn ich da kunst anschließend darf
wenn sie davon sprechen dass europa die
handlungsmacht oder die handlung ist
eine handlungs mächtigkeit jetzt im
besten sinne wieder neue oder neu finden
muss
wie würden sie dieses
vertiefend sehen wollen also wenn man
das sehr pauschal gegenüberstellt zwei
modelle wie sich eine europäische union
selbst versteht stichwort staatenbund
versus bundesstaat
und dann abgeleitet davon so ausgehend
von diesen politischen horizont
auffächerung die frage wie kann sich
eine europäische militärische
verteidigungspolitische einheit
interpretieren und ausgestalten in diese
handlungsfähigkeit
eben auch da mit blick auf die existenz
der nato und die aktuellen
verflechtungen die es daher schon lange
gibt und
man sagen kann er dann entsprechend den
jeweiligen beiden modellen
eine eu armee jetzt auch sehr pauschal
gesagt wer so seine ähnlich der nato
kommt oder ähnlich dem sozusagen
verfassungsgeschichte der dem rang der
nato entsprechend auch eine armee der
europäischen nationen die sozusagen
jeder steuert was bei was er kann und
will so gut ist wie
würden sie das hätte mich interessiert
das frage das einschätzen wenn es da
tatsächlich jetzt an der zeit ist zu
handeln und in afghanistan war ja ein
weckruf glaube ich auch für fehler
innerhalb der eu die das nicht so
gesehen haben das scheitern dort
wie würden sie das einschätzen also wenn
sie sagen dass diese handlungsmacht
gestärkt werden in welche richtung
sollte mörder sollte sich die
europäische union darauf verpflichtet
wissen sich weiterzuentwickeln
also ideal wäre natürlich wenn die 27
übereinkommen zu sagen wir schaffen das
jetzt vielleicht nicht wie die usa am
ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts aus
einer ansammlung von
einzelstaaten ein bundesstaat zu
entwickeln
das wäre sagen die wunschvorstellung
oder die idealvorstellung aber ich
glaube wenn man einigermaßen realistisch
ist wird man davon ausgehen können dass
wird darauf hinauslaufen dass die alte
lokomotive der eu also paris und berlin
das machen müssen
dass sie da eine initiative ergreifen
der sich vielleicht italiener wenn sie
sagen wir wollen
und den bedingungen dass die briten
jetzt weg sind wieder als der dritte
große dabei sein
sich dem anschließen
sodass also da ein sowie ein dreieck
entsteht und sobald das da ist werden
würde ich mal sagen die spanier und die
polin anklopfen dass sie dabei sein
dürfen und viele andere auch meinen
fans sagen außerhalb der nato ist dann
wird auch man die frage der neutralität
in wien anders bewerten müssen um
auf diese weise
sozusagen sich in eine europäische armee
einzuschleichen nicht also das weiß ich
infiltration taktik der stadt chur und
losrennen
das ist so etwas wie die europäische
methode die dieser weise immer
stattgefunden hat deswegen habe ich auch
gesagt es wird neben dem schengen raum
mit dem euroraum ein dritter raum
entstehen innerhalb des eu raums
in dem
diese dynamik stattfindet
ja aber sozusagen eine auf dauer
gestellt ja also nicht nur so jetzt
haben wir da mal ein problem wer macht
mit nicht sondern dass man so etwas weh
jetzt ist vielleicht etwas übertrieben
aber ist es dass der kopf des
kommissionspräsidenten hat auf die er
oder sie zurückgreifen kann versagen
also sie würden sich bei der kommission
an sie wollen die ich würde schon sagen
meine
alternative ist natürlich aber das hat
viel sprengkraft dass man sie irgendwie
makro und werden
in deutschland kanzler ist zunächst
einmal nicht das ist aber schwierig ja
also zu sagen was wäre schon ganz gut
wenn die die führungsrolle übernehmen
aber diese führungsrolle gewissermaßen
nicht interpretieren als eine
einsatzbefehls rolle sondern die nach
brüssel geht auch um ich habe gehört
dass ich da gesagt habe nicht
handlungsmacht in brüssel und
rückbau der regelungswut der
dortigen administration um den brüssel
dann was zu tun zu geben ja dass die
nicht ständig neue also jetzt karriere
ich natürlich wenn eine krümmung
verordnungen oder der leyen mehr sich
ausdenken sondern mit solchen
herausforderungen auch konfrontiert sind
so dass man also dann ein label
draufkleben kann europa was ja aber
aus ihren ausführungen geht schon hervor
europäische handlungsmacht ohne einer
glaubwürdigen militärischen
dimension ist nicht ist nicht denkbar
also eine reine wie sie auch natürlich
immer wieder diskutiert wird eine soft
power eine zivil macht europa die so
eine auf andere handlungs dimensionen
als die militärische setzt es wäre in
angesichts der globalen
herausforderungen nicht glaubwürdig
genug oder ja ich glaube auch dass immer
es vier machten gab im micro mann und
das beschrieben hat politische macht der
ökonomische macht kulturelle macht und
militärische macht
welches spezifische gewicht dieser
einzelnen macht sorten haben das hat
etwas mit den
allgemeinen umständen zu tun aber selbst
unter den bedingungen
dass man geglaubt hat man geht in eine
weltordnung der regel struktur und der
internationalen gerichtshöfe hinein
hatte man auf militärische macht im
sinne von so etwas wie einer
internationalen polizei
zurückgegriffen okay das wurde dann in
anderer weise
beschrieben und begriffen und in der
struktur von fünf einflussbereich und
wird sich das wieder anders
darstellen und vielleicht sollte ich
auch noch dazu sagen die abschreckung
gegenüber russland das wird vorerst eine
nato aufgabe
bleiben so dass man in dieser frage die
usa mit im boot behält denn
ich sehe nicht dass man im augenblick
sich in europa verständigen kann über
eine nukleare abschreckung komponente
nicht wir haben die franzosen in sehr
begrenzter weise wollen sie aber nicht
europäisieren aus ja vielleicht
nachvollziehbaren gründen
aber wenn andere dazu kämen nicht dann
wäre das eine sehr schwierige sache und
vermutlich wird auch die glaubwürdigkeit
sofort leiten wenn
27 gewässern war es in einer alten
einsatz entscheidung zu treffen hätten
also das braucht man schon nicht aber
das ist dann auch eine frage wie sich
das mit der zeit entwickelt diese
europäische komponente und die nato
komponente
und ösen vortagesgewinnen ist nichts von
vornherein als exklusive szenarien wie
ein neues in der sein dass man sagt wir
müssen jetzt eine grundsatzentscheidung
treffen sondern genau parallel
strip-club auch gar nicht dass die
europäer in der lage wäre eine zu sagen
so alternative entweder oder
entscheidung zu treffen sondern man muss
ihnen auf die sprünge helfen indem man
die zunächst einmal sehr als sowohl als
auch at welche auf das kann man auch aus
der militärischen praktischen sich der
durchaus bestätigen die eu-27 verfügen
ja über militärische mittel dieser dann
den organisationen zur verfügung stehen
also auch die nato hat ja keine super
nationalen kaum supranationale
gemeinsamen militärischen fähigkeiten
auch der nato werden im wesentlichen die
mittel von den mitgliedsstaaten
natürlich dem von der führungsmacht usa
insbesondere zur verfügung gestellt das
augenfällige ist nur dass bis dato die
europäischen staaten
viel weniger militärischen mitteln der
europäischen union zur verfügung stehen
sowohl also für die vorbereitung als
auch für die einsatz durch
führungsaufgaben mehr als im vergleich
zur nato und wenn es einmal von diesen
berühmten single set auf forces
gesprochen wird das wird man hat nur
einen satz an streitkräfte fähigkeiten
dem man dann zur verfügung steht wo es
gerade gebraucht wird dann wäre das
schon ein massiver fortschritt wenn wir
hier sozusagen auf einer augenhöhe kämen
dass die mitgliedstaaten der der die
europäischen staaten der nato wie auch
der eu ihre mittel zur verfügung stehen
wir immer noch gar nicht von neuen
instrumenten und glaube auch im bereich
der militärischen handlungsmacht
handlungs mächtigkeit muss man ein
zweiter ebene unterscheiden ist eine
sind natürlich die fähigkeiten die man
braucht die hardware und das andere ist
die zweite dimension ist die art der
entscheidungs logik also wer verfügt
nach welchen demokratisch legitimierten
prinzipien dann über den einsatz und ich
glaube auch dass vielleicht ein
pragmatischer schritt in der entwicklung
der europäischen verteidigungspolitik
ist wäre oder dass das problem nicht so
sehr ist das ist ein europa der in
unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten
hier gibt das kann man durchaus glaube
ich ausbalancieren tolerieren viel
entscheidender ist dass es eine
gemeinsame strategische zielrichtung
gibt auf die man hin will und dann eben
in den internen spielregeln genug
flexibilität schafft dass die staaten
die also auch hier vorangehen wollen ja
dann auch entsprechend schneller sich
auch bewegen können und der vertrag von
lissabon gibt diese möglichkeit her zum
beispiel in diesem artikel 44 kann die
europäische union eine gruppe von
staaten beauftragen in ihrem namen
vorzugehen und zu agieren was dann in
den entscheidungsabläufen in der
bereitstellung der kräfte in der
vorbereitung durchführung des einsatzes
zu einer erheblichen beschleunigung und
verbesserung der handlungsfähigkeit
führen würde aber also man kann das
vielleicht auch an einem beispiel
erläutern nicht etwa die frage wie
glaubwürdig
der nato vertrag insbesondere artikel 5
ist trump hat den jahr mehrfach in frage
gestellt und in gewisser hinsicht war
das natürlich eine einladung an wen auch
immer als und die totale russland mal
auszuprobieren ob
tatsächlich die europäer bereit wären in
kampfhandlungen einzutreten in der
verteidigung irgendeines baltischen
staates in der regel wäre das dann
erstmal estland gewesen vermutlich
nicht und
weil das nun mal schon so war würde es
auch zu einer vorausschauenden
strategie gehören sich darauf
einzustellen dass der nächste
amerikanische präsident vielleicht
artikel 5 wieder so
gemacht dass es quasi eine einladung an
russland ist mal auszuprobieren wie das
ist und in dieser situation
wäre dann eine dynamische verschiebung
von nato fähigkeiten zur europäischen
fähigkeiten der fall nicht so dass man
also sich so ausstellt dass man auf
einen bündnispolitischen worst case
vorbereitet ist und ich sage meinen das
wären die amis schon machen das haben
sie in der vergangenheit gemacht aber es
ist letzten endes längst klar dass wenn
im balkan bereich wieder probleme
auftreten die usa nicht mehr der
problemlöser sein werden wie je nach in
den 90er jahren sondern müssen die
europäer alleine hinkriegen und
sozusagen die eine herausforderung die
andere herausforderung ist sicherlich
dass bei gekommen ist professor würden
sie sich diese these auch anschließend
insbesondere nach dem abzug der
vereinigten staaten und ihrer alliierten
aus afghanistan dass diese phase der
schwäche des westens von dem man diese
alten von
der ausprägung des kalten krieges nicht
mehr sprechen kann wie sie in ein
separates geführt haben dass diese dass
diese schwäche des westens gerade in der
näheren zukunft auch von uns von von
akteuren genutzt werden könnte und genau
diese aspekte die sie angesprochen haben
auch ab zu testen also das ist das
betrifft sicher den baltischen den
osteuropäischen rahmen wir haben aber
auch dürfen nicht vergessen natürlich
die in den denn den weiteren
indopazifischen raum wo man immer wieder
natürlich auch gerade in der jüngeren
vergangenheit vermehrt entsprechende
aktivitäten setzen kann aussehen kann
aber natürlich auch die frage des des
internationalen terrorismus der die die
gruppierungen sehen sich als sieger die
haben ja aus ihrer wahrnehmung gewonnen
was werden sie sozusagen mit
militärischer immer sozusagen ausnutzung
des erfolgs ausnutzung des sieges sehen
sie jetzt dann durch diese entwicklungen
nach afghanistan bedingt jetzt gerade
noch einmal auch eine verschärfung der
sicherheitslage wenn man genau versucht
entweder diese handlungs schwäche oder
diese handlungs um sicherheit wird es
vielleicht formulieren des westens
auszunutzen um dass sie noch stärker ist
in der vergangenheit auch ab zu testen
ja gut also afghanistan ist eine es eine
komplexe geschichte
in doha haben allein die usa verhandelt
und sie haben offenbar mit den taliban
verhandlern auf der anderen seite
ausgemacht naja drei bis sieben monate
bekommen wir zeit bevor er in kabul ein
rückte mit uns nicht die bilder von
cyber wieder passieren und das hat sich
aber scheint rumgesprochen
also heiko maas hat ja im bundestag
sozusagen naiv sich darauf verlassen und
sich im fenster gelegt drei bis sieben
monaten haben wir die ortskräfte
evakuiert aber das hat scheint es auch
in der afghanischen armee
herumgesprochen gehabt deswegen haben
wir gedacht warum sollen wir eigentlich
dafür sterben dass der westen bella
figura machte nicht was ganz rationale
überlegung und dann offenbar auch die
feld kommandeure der taliban er hat eine
andere auffassung wie sie das problem
lösen wollen als diejenigen die in doha
verhandelt haben all das hat man
natürlich wissen können
der entscheidende punkt war
die sind ja nicht militärisch geschlagen
worden sondern sie haben einfach die
lust verloren oder die perspektive
darauf dass man wenn man noch mal zehn
jahre bleibt oder so dass man dann
nennenswerte erfolge hat
das ist einer der punkte über dem man
noch mal nachdenken muss in der thalia
angeblich gesagt haben soll ihr habt die
uhren wir aber haben die zeit also zeit
als strategische ressource
das weiß militär im prinzip eigentlich
aber 20 jahre ist sozusagen schon orizon
der eigentlich militärisch nicht mehr
plant wird sondern der ja irgendwo
anders landet
also darüber wird man sich auch gedanken
machen müssen in welchem zeithorizont
man denkt und bin ich gesagt habe
stabilisierung und prosperität transfer
in die peripherie die gegenüberliegende
mittelmeerküste oder derlei mehr dann
wird man das in zeit kategorien von
jahrzehnten denken müssen und nicht
sagen das ist ein einsatz der was weiß
ich relativ bald mit der aufschrift
mission accomplished oder wie auch immer
diese erfasst karnevalesken
inszenierungen dann benannt werden
entwickelt wird sondern das sind sehr
sehr langfristige dinge und da müssen
unsere gesellschaften auch einen langen
atem entwickeln und vermutlich muss da
auch militär in einer weise mit zeit
perspektiven denken die eigentlich
normalerweise und den bedingungen der
klassischen des klassischen
militärischen gebrauch militärischer
mittel
jenseits dessen liegen also ja
das alles ist eine chance im prinzip das
noch einmal auf den tisch zu bringen
will heißen interventionismus ist nicht
zu ende aber rein humanitärer
interventionismus ist zu ende und weil
ich immer zu geben würde der war nie
gefällig humanitär sollen wurde auch
immer durch eigeninteressen gehärtet
nicht also wenn der damalige
verteidigungsminister in deutschland
struck gesagt hat deutschlands
sicherheit wird auch am hindukusch
verteidigt dann weit ist der versuch
gewissermaßen ein eigenes interesse in
die humanitäre
argumentation der bringen dorthin
menschenrechte frauenrechte was auch
immer er hinein zu tun aber nicht wenn
wir über dem mittelmeer küste geben
überlegten die afrikanischen nachdenken
wenn sind sehr viel stärker
unmittelbare europäische
verwundbarkeiten im zentrum weiß dass im
falle afghanistan der fall war da hat
sich herausgestellt
vermutlich muss man dafür um terroristen
das war der zweite punkt den sie
angesprochen haben
strukturell zu schwächen nicht mehr ein
ganzes land umgraben
wie das ja die idee war das überfordert
uns sondern
auf die asymmetrische herausforderung
netzwerke nicht territorialer art die
aus der tiefe des sozialen raums heraus
agieren setzt man eine kombination von
spielen kampfdrohnen die diese netzwerke
an zentralen punkten angreifen und
zerreißen und auf diese weise in
strategische angriffs fähigkeit nehmen
das ist nicht besonders appetitlich so
das ist auch eigentlich jenseits aller
vorstellungen von klassischem
kriegsrecht
aber
darüber hat man jetzt im falle
afghanistan nicht geredet aber das ist
die fortsetzung des kampfes gegen den
terrorismus mit anderen mitteln und
ansonsten wird das taliban-regime
durchaus ein interesse daran haben
zu verhindern dass sich terroristische
gruppen bei ihnen einnisten das problem
haben sie ja schon gegenwärtig mit den
us ableger
so dass man sagen kann naja also da hat
dann die politik übernommen in dem sinne
dass das taliban-regime bisherige gegner
in einer rolle rein kommt dass er
gewisse sicherheitsaufgaben für den
westen übernehmen wird das gehört auch
dann zur paradoxie politische spiele
dazu also irgendwo auch die erkenntnis
dass der aktuelle status quo rauch in
bezug auf die sicherheit nicht
nachhaltig nicht durchhaltefähig ist
weil er immer wieder die andere akteure
diese handlung schwäche des westens auch
gezielt weiter und weiter
nutzen werden und gegen sie ausrichten
werden aber auch angesprochen kultur als
eine dimension der macht und hier möchte
ich dr bergdolt hereinbringen mit der
mit der frage welche bedeutung hat
kultur als grund gemeinsame ein
gemeinsames würde jetzt sagen
freiheitsverständnis ein gemeinsames
verständnis eines europäischen freiheits
und gesellschaftsmodell für
als basis als grundlage für
sicherheitspolitisches für aus- und
politisches handeln ja danke möchte
anschließend das was der professor
gesagt habe an den langen atem und was
sie gesagt haben in ihren referaten
nämlich das universelle werte nicht mehr
global durchgesetzt werden können davon
müssten wir uns verabschieden das bringt
führt mich auf das was sie angeschnitten
haben wir gerne dass wir diesen langen
atem in europa wohl nicht haben werden
wenn es nicht auch so was wie eine
geistige landesverteidigung gibt oder
ein selbstbewusstsein 1 1 wer wille in
europa der sich auch in der bevölkerung
widerspiegelt und wer nicht ausgelagert
wird auch durch die neuen
herausforderungen dass amerika sich
vielleicht etwas zurückzieht europa
eigentlich dominanter werden muss
intensivieren muss die gemeinsame außen
und sicherheitspolitik aber das
funktioniert eben nur wenn wir auch
diese gemeinsamen werte und normen als
für uns verbindlich und verteidigungs
wert
diskutieren und auch erkennen und ich
glaube da da wäre wenn wenn ich jetzt
das so wahr nehme das dass europa mehr
investieren muss in die
gemeinsame außen- sicherheits- politik
sei es jetzt auch leistungsmäßig sie
haben auch die die die die flugzeug
herstellung gemeinsam und so weiter
thematisiert muss auch in der geistigen
landesverteidigung mehr investiert
werden in der bildungspolitik in der
integrationspolitik die er letztlich
auch
sozusagen damit zusammenhängt warum hat
belarus wird es erwähnt haben die hier
eine schwäche europas entdeckt damit
umzugehen zu lernen dass die
migranten hier auch für ein europäisches
selbstbewusstsein stehen können und dazu
braucht es aber auch die die
argumentation dass diese ich nenne es
trotzdem universellen werte die europa
vertritt
dialog würdig fähig sind und
auch anerkannt werden müssen in der
integrations migrationspolitik also
zumindest innerhalb europas muss glaube
ich diese debatte geführt werden ja
völlig recht meine
versteht die fragt zunächst mal in der
tradition des namensgebers dieses hauses
nicht von von general spann okay
wir sind eine post heroische
gesellschaft
das heißt aber nicht dass wir eine
prinzipiell um heroische gesellschaft es
glaube ich diesen begriff der
postalischen gesellschaft jedenfalls als
merkmal einer ganzen gesellschaft
geprägt
das heißt so zu sagen wir schauen
betroffen zurück auf die geschichte der
ersten hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts das glaube ich kann ich für
uns für die bundesrepublik deutlich
leichter als auch für die republik
österreich sagen
mit der vorstellung das wird nicht mehr
sein nicht
aus vielerlei gründen aufgrund der
demographischen struktur wird das nicht
mehr sein dass man sage nur was soll
jetzt ein paar millionen oder so wir
führen diese auseinandersetzung
das heißt wir haben uns von einer
bestimmten form verabschiedet ein für
allemal aber das heißt nicht dass diese
gesellschaften prinzipiell unruhig sind
sie müssen nur eine vorstellung davon
haben wo für sie das sind nicht und
sozusagen allein für wohlstand das ist
sozusagen zu wenig
also muss man auch noch mal über über
werte nachdenken allerdings in dieser
bescheideneren form es sind unsere werte
und weiß gott die 27 in europa sind
vollauf damit beschäftigt diese werte
bei sich selber in geltung zu setzen
und auch zu vermitteln mit allen
schwierigkeiten die dazugehören und wir
sollten darauf verzichten
sozusagen als oberlehrer der welt
aufzutreten und ständig die bei anderen
anzumachen nicht wenn ich von diesen
fünf einflusszonen gesprochen habe heißt
dass auch die haben ihre eigenen werte
die chinesen haben nun mal ihre eigenen
werde und sie werden den teufel tun
plötzlich zu sagen ja aber die
europäischen werte die weniger die
gemeinschaft mir das individuum in den
mittelpunkt stellen und von daher ihre
rechts fuhr aufbauen die werden wir
jetzt übernehmen nein diese entscheidung
ist glaube ich noch unter denken mit der
niederschlagung der bewegung auf dem
platz des himmlischen friedens gelaufen
und sie ist ein für alle mal gelaufen
und vielleicht ist das auch im hinblick
auf die islamische welt so
aber das heißt sozusagen nicht dass wir
im inneren
der europäischen union so etwas wie
einen ethischen relativismus
verfallen ja alles geht alles
es sowieso wurst und derlei mehr
und
darüber muss man muss man natürlich
nachdenken wie man das so organisieren
kann dass das reden über werte nicht zum
spaltpilz der europäischen union wird
das ist ja etwas was wir im augenblick
ganz schön beobachten können wie
gewissermaßen das identitätsmerkmal
dass europa projekt das unter der hand
zum spaltpilz wird
also un zu sagen man darf es auch nicht
zu hoch fahren
denn
wenn man das gewissermaßen
normativ sehr hoch aufstellt dann werden
einige sagen aber aber wir sind dann
nicht mehr der fall hätten wir wollen
dann auch nicht dabei sein
da gehört es halt sozusagen zur
spannweite der europäischen ordnung dazu
dass die ausgestaltung dieser werte in
gleich einzelnen ländern in einzelnen
regionen sehr unterschiedlich ist
im augenblick kann man ja in deutschland
beobachten oder in deutschland die
impfrate im norden ist sehr viel höher
als die im süden warum ist das so ja ich
kann auch nicht sagen seid was mit
katholisch und evangelisch zu tun weil
die sachsen sind wenn sie überhaupt was
sind evangelisch aber sie haben trotzdem
eine niedrige impfrate und so weiter und
so weiter also da gibt es sehr viele
sehr viele unterschiede und das ist ja
auch eine frage gewissermaßen der werte
und normen ob ich seine freiheit schafft
mit dem flüsschen auf und verstehe dass
im sinne von max stirner der einzige und
sein eigentum oder aber ob ich eher im
sinne von kant als
freiheit die ich in anspruch nehmen kann
und in der voraussetzung dass er mit der
freiheit eines jeden anderen zusammen
bestehen kann und das ist sozusagen ganz
anderes argument zwar glaube ich sehr
interessante aspekte angesprochen dass
also sowohl von der von der also die
auch werte nicht a priori dazu beitragen
müssen dass sie die gesellschaft einen
ja und eine selbe beobachtung müssen wir
auch aus der sicherheitspolitischer
sicht machen dass zunehmend risiken
man eigentlich der meinung sein könnte
wenn es einen staat eine gemeinschaft
mit externen risiken konfrontiert ist
dass sie dann zusammen rückt das risiko
zusammen so kohärenz von gemeinschaften
beiträgen dass wir hier auch zunehmend
feststellen müssen dass die modernen
risiko bildet im modernen
sicherheitsrelevanten szenarien auch ein
hohes spaltung potenzial haben wir sehen
wir haben das gesehen ganz massiv in der
frage der migrations krise oder frage
wie soll außen grenzschutz funktionieren
oder nicht funktionieren wir haben
aktuell die debatte um
wie man effizientesten mit der pandemie
natürlich umgeht ja wir haben
unterschiedliche zugänge und
einschätzungen hinsichtlich russland
hinsichtlich chinas also äußere risiken
ebenso wie die wertedebatte haben
auftragen offensichtlich nicht
automatisch dazu bei dass die
gesellschaft und die stadt die menschen
enger zusammenrücken sondern wir haben
auch mindestens gleiches sparpotenzialen
insel hier darf ich dann anschließend
eine bemerkung dazu und damit knüpften
deiner frage der wertbegriffe so kant
hat ja der berühmte maßen der
bekanntermaßen darauf hingewiesen wert
ist per se etwas relatives also wert hat
eigentlich dann auch seinen gehen um den
ort am markt sozusagen der wert eines
gutes bemisst sich an seinem ort in dem
funktionalen ganzen des wirtschaftlichen
verkehr etc
das heißt eigentlich ist es schon
personen kontraktion objekte hier in
bezug auf
diese die quelle dessen woraus wir
unsere kulturelle identität
verstehen mit diesem terminus des wertes
zu versehen weil das hat ja berühmter
maßen nietzsche wie visionen wissen mit
der umwertung aller werte eigentlich
eher zum ausdruck gebracht also dh und
das führt mich jetzt zur frage also dass
die werte spalten also sie können um
gewertet werden und sind diesen
perspektivisch muss in gewisser weise
unterworfen die frage jetzt in
anknüpfung an ihre letzte aus an ihrer
letzten ausführungen wäre im gespräch
mit kollegen beachten wo würden denn sie
so was wie jetzt ja nicht
relativistische sinn gemeint also die
gesellschaft also wohlstandssicherung
alleine kann es nicht sein um im rahmen
einer postheroischen gesellschaft so
etwas wie den willen zum selbst sein zu
kultivieren zu geld zu machen ja also
wenn sie jetzt sagen wir müssen wir
müssen so einen willen entwickeln im
sinne der handlungs mächtigkeit dann
braucht sozusagen einen geistigen ist
formuliert sehr technizistischen motor
es braucht eine quelle aus der sich das
rausschmeißt und die kann sozusagen das
wäre aber im widerspruch zu sagen das
ist sozusagen ein relativer wert weil
sowas kann es nicht sein weil die so zur
bereitschaft seinen wohlstand seinen
leib und leben möglicherweise eben für
etwas aufzugeben im sinne des
vermittelten terrorismus der sich der
reflexiv vermittelt darüber der kann ja
niemals auf sondern weil das ist immer
der widerspruch warum soll ich etwa des
söldners warum ich gehe in einem vertrag
ein aber sozusagen ist es sinnlos
mein leben hier preiszugeben weil da
werde ich niemandem eine gage erhalten
das heißt also der vipnet zu letzten
dinge nie bereit sondern dieser
aufopferung für eine gemeinschaft und
jetzt wäre meine frage diejenigen wo
sehen sie denn jetzt material nicht er
inhaltlich sinn ressourcen die in europa
da sind wo man hier andocken müsste oder
die man in der bildungspolitik oder die
mama geltend machen sollte inhaltlicher
art um das um diese die umsetzung da
diese handlungs mächtigkeit
weiterzubringen
also das christentum ist es sicherlich
nicht mehr auch nicht mehr der rekurs
auf die lateinische christenheit nächte
sagt okay das andere ist byzanz und
russland als nachfolgeorganisation
dafür sind wir viel zu stark säkularen
gesellschaften und natürlich auch
multireligiöse gesellschaft
vermutlich ist der individualismus und
das ansetzen daran sozusagen etwas was
auf das individuum
als einen selbst bezüglichen werte
träger
kreist dass das am ehesten
für die 27 ins zentrum zu stellen das
aber stimmt die länder leichter in
anderen sehr viel zu jung dass
nationalismus dann aber das spielt nicht
so könnte man trug den einmal machen
aber das ist ist das nicht bloß der bus
der nicht der bürger ist das sieht durch
also im sinne dieses individualismus er
gut
aber das ist natürlich die grundlage des
liberalen verständnisses nicht sozusagen
der liberalismus
ist die formulierung von zentralen
werten im hinblick auf den einzelnen und
die ermächtigung des einzelnen der
verzicht darauf ihre tugenden
vorzuschreiben und derlei mehr ich will
nicht verhehlen dass ich immer eine
gewisse sympathie für republikanische
vorstellungen nahte in denen der tugend
diskurs eine sehr viel stärkere rolle
spielt ich würde auch immer sagen ja das
ist auch für unsere eigenen
augenblickliche situation nicht
uninteressant etwa eine jedenfalls auf
bestimmte berufsgruppen durchzusetzen
etwa wäre ein solches republikanisches
argument in der nicht entscheidet
darüber also sozusagen joshua chemisch
sondern die verantwortung die sich mit
ihr verbindet im hinblick auf
das wird man neue austarierung muss man
noch einmal darüber nachdenken ob man
sozusagen allein auf dem individualismus
eine ordnung aufbauen kann die
selbstbehauptungs fähig ist was ja die
ausgangsvoraussetzungen ist nicht heute
aber ob das na ja wenn ich ein rechter
wäre würde ich sagen spät roma also
gewissermaßen eine decke der
gesellschaft
darstellt bin ich aber nicht und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass ende werde
individuell aufgestellte gesellschaften
durchaus zu solchen
republikanischen minimal vorstellungen
kommen können
und
die intellektuelle auseinandersetzung
verbessert und noch mal auf ihren traum
zurückzukommen die wir in den nächsten
jahren zu führen haben ist tendenziell
das verhältnis zwischen republikanischen
ideen also letzten endes
gewissen gemeinwohl vorstellungen im
weitesten sinne auf der einen seite und
dem kern unserer
krach was weiß ich nicht nur europäische
auch amerikanischen identität nämlich
die begründung der politischen ordnung
von den rechten und ansprüchen des
individuums
das auszutarieren
das ist eine wirklich spannende
diskussion
die man auch nicht so auflösen kann wie
ich das in frankfurt werden meines
damaligen philosophie studiums in den
70er jahren gelernt habe nicht abermals
vorschlag wir lassen das mit den werten
und denken dass allein über neuerungen
nicht weil werte malgruppen bezogen sind
aber norman kann man universalisierung
so wird man es nicht nicht auflösen
können das glaube ich hat sich auch
gezeigt
aber die europäer brauchen sagen ein
gleichgewicht zwischen zwischen beidem
und
das ist am besten wenn man das nicht von
der universität hermacht und verachtet
sondern wenn in einer gemeinsamen
anstrengung
eine mehrheit der bürger zu alle wird
mit anni involvieren können zu
bestimmten ergebnissen kommen
in denen sie sagen was zu sagen für sie
die republikanische komponente es und
wie weit das mit der freiheit gibt und
in gewisser hinsicht
beobachten wir hier zurzeit auch so
etwas in der frage des umgangs mit der
pandemie und dem impfen und derlei mehr
wie eine selbstverständigung der
gesellschaften darüber
was man bereit es auch an
einschränkungen individuellen willens
auf sich zu nehmen
um nicht zu einem biotop für die
permanente mutationen des virus zu
werden und so weiter und so weiter nicht
und
das ist sozusagen nicht mehr da bin ich
auch empirisch
sozialwissenschaftler das ist auch so
etwas wie ein nahaufnahme unserer
gesellschaft jetzt nicht nur so
beliebig befragt von allensbach oder wem
auch immer was man dafür denkt dann was
man ja hier verlinkt sondern es ist eine
beobachtung von willen nicht und da kann
man schon sagen stehen die europäer zur
zeit nicht ganz gut da und
das ist eine aufforderung ich muss
bisschen abseits pc hackten und da das
vorrecht des moderators noch für die
letzte frage
wie vor behalten und zwar sie sehen sie
auch über viele jahre hinweg schon sehr
wichtiger und und wegweiser in der
mitautor in unserer jährlichen
sicherheitspolitischen jahres vor schaut
die immer einen ausblick auf die
nächsten 12 bis 18 monate markt welche
herausforderungen auf die
österreichische sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik zu kommen daher
also habe ich mir auch die abschließende
frage welche drei zentralen risiken
herausforderungen für die
österreichische für die europäische
sicherheitspolitik in den 12 bis 18
monaten würden sie mit priorität ziehen
also speziell was österreich betrifft
ist natürlich der
angrenzenden raum
sozusagen bis zu reggae ist
von besonderer relevanz und dass die
verhältnisse in bosnien herzegowina zur
zeit nicht besonders gut sind und nord
mazedonien
und eigentlich gibt es gar kein land bei
dem man sagen kann da sind stabile
fortschritte die irreversibel sind
gemacht worden dass ein punkt der
natürlich andere europäische länder in
weniger begriff betrifft also die
spanier werden sich damit nicht
beschäftigen wollen und die baltischen
staaten auch nicht
ein punkt der zweite punkt ist zu
beobachten
wie sich die russen weiter verhalten
gibt sozusagen ja widersprüchliche
signale erkennbar protein stützt
lukaschenka andererseits hat er sich
bereit erklärt die gasspeicher in europa
jetzt wieder aufzufüllen
also sage nein ein vernünftiges cream
und mit einer macht hinzubekommen die
einerseits partner dimension hat und
andererseits widersacher dimension das
ist der zweite punkt
und der dritte punkt sind wir noch mal
bei der pandemie
ich glaube nicht dass man sagen kann mit
19 war eine jahrhundert pandemie was so
viel heißt na ja für das 21 jahrhundert
haben jetzt die herausforderung pandemie
abgefrühstückt und es passiert nichts
mehr sondern wir sind eigentlich in ein
jahrhundert der pandemien hineingegangen
das
hat vielerlei gründe
und die wollen wir es schaffen
also zunächst einmal natürlich auch
österreich es schaffen damit in zukunft
umzugehen also resilienz aufzubauen im
hinblick auf solche herausforderungen
und das ist dann auch eine europäische
frage wie wollen wir es verhindern
dass impfstoff knappheit eintritt oder
am anfang muss man da massen kaufen und
bei den chinesen betteln dass die
wartungs geräte liefern und der leyen
also werden wir auf europäischer ebene
durch halte sich gegenüber
herausforderung von denen man denke ich
glaube ich an allen zehn fingern
abzählen kann dass sie sich wiederholen
oder tendenziell zu einem ständigen
begleiter des 21 jahrhunderts werden
sehr geehrte professor für das der bund
schlägt auf dem berg deutlich bedanke
mich für diese sehr breit gefächerte
diskussion hat mir wieder einmal gezeigt
dass
verteidigungspolitik auf sehr sehr
vielen voraussetzungen beruht sie sich
militär selbst nicht geben kann von der
inneren kohärenz von gesellschaften von
der entwicklung einer gemeinsamen
strategischen kultur bis hin zu fragen
der politischen leadership
ich denke daher wir haben genug stoff
auch identifiziert um unsere
diskussionen auch gemeinsam fortzusetzen
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat bei ihnen interesse geweckt wenn
sie weiterhin
interesse an den aktivitäten unseres
instituts haben so darf ich sie herzlich
einladen uns auf diversen sozialen
medien im internet auf unserer homepage
oder über twitter oder über facebook zu
folgen und bedanke mich für interesse
und noch einmal recht herzlichen dank an
unseren gastreferenten ein spannender
faszinierender vormittag herzlichen dank